[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg der letzte Abend vor
Weihnachten schön dass Sie dabei sind
wie auch Norbert Lehmann für den Sport
ganz von mir und das sind die Themen von
heute
Vorwurf Landesverrat nach der Festnahme
eines bnd-mitarbeiters zeigt sich die
Politik besorgt offenbar hatte er Zugang
zu brisanten Informationen
tödliche Schüsse in Paris ein Mann
erschießt drei Menschen an einem
kurdischen Kulturzentrum möglicherweise
aus rassistischen Gründen
und extreme Kaltfront ein gewaltiger
Wintersturm stürzt weite Teile der USA
kurz vor Weihnachten ins Chaos
[Musik]
ein Weckruf besonders bedenklich der
Fall zeige wie wachsam wir sein müssen
das sind einige der Reaktionen auf die
Enttarnung des mutmaßlichen doppelspions
beim Bundesnachrichtendienst der
Mitarbeiter des deutschen
Auslandsgeheimdienstes soll
Staatsgeheimnisse an Russland
weitergegeben haben Andreas kühners
berichtet
in den russischen Fernsehen Nachrichten
kein einziger Hinweis auf den
Spionagefall der die Beziehungen zu
Deutschland noch weiter verschlimmert
nicht gestern nicht heute kein Wort in
Deutschland dagegen werden Fragen Sorgen
und Aufrufe zu mehr Wachsamkeit laut der
Wirtschaftsminister appelliert auch an
die Wirtschaft sich vor russischer
Spionage zu schützen in der Grundannahme
dass alle wissen dass zwar
Handelsbeziehungen notwendig und gut
sind aber dass wir nicht
naiv und doof sein dürfen
und unser Interessen schützen müssen
muss man natürlich eine gewisse
Kontrolle immer anlegen und durchziehen
und das machen die Dienste finde ich wie
man gestern gesehen hat sehr gut über
den Festgenommenen Kasten l wird nur
wenig bekannt er soll nach einem Bericht
des Fokus Spezialist für die Auswertung
sämtlicher Informationen gewesen sein
die der BND durch Abhöraktionen gewann
mit Zugriff auch auf die Erkenntnisse
befreundeter Dienste der BND hat den
mutmaßlichen Maulwurf selbst enttarnt
und den Generalbundesanwalt
eingeschaltet noch gilt es als unmöglich
Umfang und folgendes spionagefalls
abzuschätzen vor allem nicht die
Reaktionen Russlands es reizt sich ein
in vielfältige Formen der hybriden
Kriegsführung durch russische Stellen
angefangen von klassischer Spionage bis
hin zu Mordanschlägen auf deutschen
Boden und gipfelnd in diesen
Desinformationskampagne die wir seit
Jahren erleben
der BND will keine weiteren
Informationen veröffentlichen und
verweist auf die Gewaltbereitschaft und
Skrupellosigkeit der Gegenseite
die massive corona-welle in China
beunruhigt auch andere Länder sie
fürchten wirtschaftliche Folgen wenn die
Lieferketten noch mehr ins Stocken
geraten zudem besteht die Sorge von
neuen corona-varianten den Vorstoß eines
CDU-Politikers alle Flugverbindungen
nach China zu stoppen weiß das
Verkehrsministerium zurück es gäbe
ohnehin kaum noch Flüge dorthin über die
Situation vor Ort berichtet Alexandra
Vacano
Leichensack an Leichensack Bilder die
aus dem Beerdigungsinstitut in
chunking-stammsäulen im Südwesten von
China
vor diesem Krematorium in Peking stauen
sich die Leichenwagen
die Krankenhäuser überfüllt in der
Notaufnahme hier in der Region Hunan
haben sie gerade fast 300 Patienten
täglich
einige der älteren Patienten sind in
einem ernsten Zustand deshalb stehen wir
unter einem ziemlich großen Druck
nach der Null corvette-politik rollt
jetzt die corona-welle über das große
Land das eine Problem ist dass die
Impfstoffe eben den mRNA Impfstoffen die
im Westen angewendet worden sind
hauptsächlich unterlegen sind dann haben
die Chinesen als erstes eben nicht wie
bei uns die älteren Menschen also die
gefährdetsten Menschen geimpft jetzt
aber steige die Impfquote der Impfstoffe
der der angepasst versichert die
Sprecherin des Außenministeriums der
Welt doch mit schätzungsweise einer
Millionen Infektionen am Tag wächst die
Angst von neuen gefährlichen
corona-varianten das soll chinesische
Gesundheitsbehörden jetzt genauer in den
Blick nehmen die neue Welle auch eine
Gefahr für Deutschland
in der deutschen Bevölkerung zum
Beispiel haben über 95% Antikörper und
alle die die Infektion schon
durchgemacht haben vor allen Dingen dann
auch nach Impfung die haben auch noch
zusätzlich einen andere einen anderen
Schutz durchs Immunsystem nämlich
sogenannte T-Zellen und die führen dazu
dass wir nicht mehr schwer erkranken
können
corona-chaos dagegen in China jetzt
drängt die Regierung
Medikamentenhersteller dazu schneller
Schmerzmittel zu produzieren
in die USA dort hat der Haushaltsentwurf
für kommendes Jahr die erste Hürde im
Senat genommen und die Hälfte des 1,7
Billionen US-Dollar etas entfallen auf
Verteidigung vorgesehen sind auch 45
Milliarden für die weitere Unterstützung
der Ukraine das ist mehr als Präsident
beiden zuletzt gefordert hatte das Paket
muss jetzt noch durch das
Repräsentantenhaus die Zustimmung gilt
als sicher
im Streit über die Einhaltung
rechtsstaatlicher Grundsätze erhöht die
EU den Druck auf Ungarn die Kommission
will in den kommenden fünf Jahren 22
Milliarden Euro zurückhalten wenn Ungarn
nicht Reformen vornimmt die
EU-Kommission sieht in Ungarn etwa die
Unabhängigkeit der justizgefährdet und
die Freiheit der Wissenschaft
Schock und Panik in Paris heute an einem
kurdenzentrum erschoss ein Mann drei
Menschen drei weitere sind zum Teil
schwer verletzt Präsident macron sprach
am Abend von einem absichtlichen Angriff
auf Kurden der mutmaßliche Täter ein
69-jähriger Franzose war schon mal wegen
einer Gewalttat aufgefallen nach dem
Angriff heute kam es zu gewaltsamen
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen kurdischen
Demonstranten und der Polizei aus Paris
Berg
die Stimmung ist aufgeheizt im 10
arrondissement von Paris Barrikaden
brennen Menschen fordern mehr Schutz von
der Polizei auch mit Gewalt und die
Polizei antwortet mit Tränengas in den
vergangenen Stunden haben sich hier
immer mehr Menschen versammelt hier in
der Nähe eines kurdischen
Gemeindezentrums wo am Mittag drei
Menschen erschossen und weitere zum Teil
schwer verletzt wurden
es waren sieben oder acht Schüsse weil
der Kerl weiter geschossen hat aber er
konnte dann nicht mehr schließen weil
keine Kugeln mehr in seinem Magazin
waren kurz danach nimmt die Polizei
einen 69-Jährigen Franzosen Fest der war
laut Pariser Staatsanwaltschaft bereits
Polizei bekannt letztes Jahr soll er mit
einem Säbel bewaffnet Menschen
angegriffen haben die in Zelten
schliefen darunter waren auch Migranten
seit kurzem war er wieder auf freien Fuß
ich habe die Polizei Dienststellen in
Paris und anderswo auf dem Staatsgebiet
gebeten die Orte zu schützen an denen
sich die kurdische Gemeinschaft ver
sowie die türkischen diplomatischen
Vertretungen wo Polizeikräfte Wache
halten werden wir wollen in dieser
besonderen Zeit des jahresendes jede
Schwierigkeit oder Fortsetzung vermeiden
ob diese Tat rassistisch motiviert war
wird jetzt geprüft der festgenommene
Mann soll noch im Krankenhaus sein und
vernommen werden mittlerweile beruhigt
sich die Lage am Tatort langsam nach
einem gewaltvollen Tag ein trauriger
Vorweihnachtsabend in Paris
für Menschen hatte er vor einem Jahr in
einem ICE in Bayern mit einem Messer zum
Teil schwer verletzt heute verurteilte
das Oberlandesgericht München den
Angeklagten zu 14 Jahren Haft wegen
gefährlicher Körperverletzung und
versuchten Mordes der 28-Jährige
Palästinenser aus Syrien hätte die Tat
aufgrund seiner islamistisch
salafistischen Überzeugung verübt und
sei voll schuldfähig so das Gericht
sexistische Bemerkungen peinliche
Auftritte der Skandal um die
Arbeiterwohlfahrt all das hatte zur
Abwahl von Frankfurts Oberbürgermeister
Feldmann geführt heute nun fiel das
juristische Urteil gegen den
SPD-Politiker eine Geldstrafe wegen
Vorteilsannahme zu Unrecht wie er findet
er habe die Höchststrafe schon erhalten
sagte er gestern weil er mit Helme
überschüttet worden sei und sein
großartigen Job verloren habe Susanna
und Peter Wagner berichten
der von Peter Feldmanns Anwalt
geforderte Freispruch blieb aus der
ehemalige Oberbürgermeister von
Frankfurt wurde wegen Vorteilsannahme im
Amt zu einer Geldstrafe von 120
Tagessätzen auch 175 € verurteilt er
gilt damit als vorbestraft das Gericht
urteilte das Feldmann seine Stellung
genutzt hat um seiner damaligen
Lebensgefährtin eine Anstellung als
Leiterin eine AWO Kindertagesstätte zu
verschaffen für die sie über Tarif
bezahlt wurde außerdem soll die
Frankfurter Arbeiterwohlfahrt den
Oberbürgermeister im Wahlkampf 2018
durch einen Werbung von Spenden
unterstützt haben
diese Unterstützung erfolgte auch
deswegen weil man auf ein späteres
Wohlwollen und eine Geneigtheit des
Oberbürgermeisters während seiner
Amtsführung für die Arbeiterwohlfahrt
hoffte wichtig für die Beweisführung sei
gewesen so dass Gericht das Feldmann der
früher für die AWO gearbeitet hat mit
deren damaligen Vorsitzenden Richter
nachweislich eine Rückkehr Vereinbarung
getroffen hat falls er nicht als OP
wiedergewählt wird
man hat gesehen dass schon seit dem Jahr
2012 diese Beziehung zwischen hannelor
Richter und Herrn Feldmann geprägt war
von Vorteilsgewährung im November wurde
Feldmann von den Frankfurtern als ob
gewählt zu viele peinliche Auftritte die
da sind Reißen des Pokals nach dem Sieg
der Eintracht in der Europa League der
Peter fällt man nun vorbestraft ist
könnte ihm der Verlust seiner
Pensionsansprüche drohen seine Anwälte
prüfen ob sie in Revision gehen
Pandemie Krieg hohe Energiekosten viele
Krisen haben dem Einzelhandel in diesem
Jahr zu schaffen gemacht so kämpfen
einige Branchen nach wie vor mit Corona
bedingten Lieferengpässen hinzu kommt
die Inflation von 10%, das alles wirkt
sich auf die Kauflaune aus die war
zuletzt eher gedrückt viele
Einzelhändler hofften aufs
Weihnachtsgeschäft doch auch das ist
durchwachsen zeigt Markus wolfhöfer
die Wiesbadener Händlerin Judith
Winkelmann hat in diesen Tagen viel Zeit
um die Kuscheldecken zu sortieren und
die Kissen einzuräumen ihrem
Einrichtungshaus gähnende Lehrer
Ernüchterung statt Kaufrausch 20%
weniger Kunden als sonst vor Weihnachten
heißt auch weniger Umsatz so ein paar
klassische
Weihnachtsgeschenke die vielleicht
mitgenommen wurden sag ich mal das ist
weggefallen das Geschäft wie Judith
Winkelmann geht es vielen Händlern nach
einem vergleichsweise guten Start hat
das Weihnachtsgeschäft dann Schwung
verloren in Zeiten hoher Inflation muss
die Bescherung in vielen kleiner
ausfallen mal guckt hat schon ein
bisschen genauer was man den Leuten dann
käuft weil bei dem Preis im Moment muss
man dann einfach machen ich bin manchmal
ja schon längst Opa und habe auch einige
Enkelkinder ich will den Zahn zu
versorgen aber doch zu beschenken und da
drehe ich auch schon mal den Euro herum
logisch am besten lief es noch in den
Bereichen lebensmittelbekleidung und
Sport trotzdem rechnet die Branche
insgesamt mit einem Weihnachtsumsatz von
120 Milliarden Euro an Minus von 4% im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr der
Einzelhandelsverband warnt deshalb vor
langfristig negativen Folgen Filialen
werden geschlossen die nicht mehr
rentabel sind oder die nicht mehr
attraktiv sind und auch der Mittelstand
verabschiedet sich zum Teil und das ist
schon eine große Herausforderung
insbesondere für die Kleinen und
Mittelstädte denn dort soll ja auch
morgen noch eine attraktives
Einzelhandelsangebot sein viele Händler
blicken nun auf die traditionell
umsatzstarke Zeit zwischen den Jahren
und die Hoffnung ist groß dass es 2023
wieder besser wird
wir blicken ins südliche
Nordrhein-Westfalen in die Gemeinde
Swisttal vor anderthalb Jahren als die
Flut kam sei es hier so aus jetzt feiern
sie das zweite Weihnachten nach dem
Unwetter viele ernüchtert denn der
Wiederaufbau geht nur langsam voran rund
150 Häuser in der Region sind immer noch
unbewohnbar was hilft ist der große
Zusammenhalt der Betroffenen Dominik
Müller vor Ort
sie stehen noch immer vor Trümmern in
einem Rohbau Familie ponsens im
örtchenmetternich in der Voreifel kein
Strom keine Heizung keine Fenster das
einzige das fertig ist ist das Fachwerk
sonst nichts schildern Sie zwei Helfern
so Joscha der hier liebte musste wieder
zu seiner Mutter ziehen
äh die hatten wir schlafen jede Nacht
schlecht mein Mann fährt jeden Morgen
hier runter und guckt ob es weitergeht
also wir sind eigentlich seit anderthalb
Jahren mit Flut beschäftigt ne das
Problem das Bauunternehmen das sie
beauftragt haben kriegt die Handwerker
nicht zusammen
Lieferengpässe keine Handwerker oder
Streit mit der Versicherung viele
Familien in der Gegend stehen vor
ähnlichen Problemen um sie machen sich
die Helfer große Sorgen das Haus
bröckelt quasi vor sich hin und es
passiert nicht viel und bei den Menschen
ist das ganz genauso die gehen immer
weiter an das Limit ihrer Kraft und
irgendwann ist dann halt auch Ende und
einige haben das Ende auch schon
erreicht und die wollen dann auch
einfach nicht mehr große Erschöpfung
beobachtet auch Fahrerin Claudia Müller
Bück es kommt vieles wieder hoch zum nun
zweiten Weihnachten im Zeichen der Flut
ich glaube es wird immer im Bewusstsein
der Menschen bleiben die Schwere der
Erfahrung der Flut aber auch all das
Positive was Menschen danach erfahren
haben also bewahrt worden zu sein Hilfe
erfahren zu haben eine Gemeinschaft ist
entstanden von Menschen die alle
dasselbe erlebt haben und immer noch
erleben sie sehnen sich nach einem
Abschluss
mit extremen Wetterbedingungen über die
Weihnachtstage müssen in diesem Jahr die
Menschen in den USA rechnen schon jetzt
sind viele Orts die Straßen mit Frost
und Schnee überzogen drei Menschen
starben bereits der Wetterdienst waren
vor einem historischen Wintersturm er
zieht vom Norden Richtung Ostküste mit
massiven Schneefällen und extremer Kälte
hier lila eingefärbt Benjamin Daniel
berichtet
manchmal ist Schönheit trügerisch denn
eine Gefahr die dieser eisige
Wintersturm mit sich bringt kann man
weniger sehen dafür aber umso mehr
spüren bei Temperaturen von bis zu minus
40 Grad und lebensbedrohlichen windböden
die Temperaturen in Verbindung mit der
Windstärke schaffen mancherorts ein für
Menschen gefährliches Umfeld innerhalb
von Minuten kann die Haut regelrecht
einfrieren wir raten den Leuten daher so
wenig rauszugehen wie möglich und Reisen
nur anzutreten wenn es sein muss bis
sich die Bedingungen verbessert haben
trotzdem planen Millionen Amerikaner zu
ihren Liebsten zu fliegen zumindest
versuchen Sie es mehr als 3000 Flüge
wurden heute bereits gestrichen
jedes Mal wenn ich versuche umzubuchen
steigen die Preise es ist
nervenaufreibend und ich hoffe dass ich
noch wegkommen kann
das nach der Pandemie viele Leute wieder
Reisen ist gut aber die Behörden sollten
besser darauf vorbereitet sein
mehrere Staaten haben den Notstand
ausgerufen der us-verkehrsminister warnt
heute besonders die rund 100 Millionen
Autofahrer die sich an den Feiertagen
auf die Straße begeben wollen
ich bitte Sie eindringlich ich weiß wir
alle wollen an den Feiertagen zu unseren
liebsten aber bitte bitte achten Sie
darauf was die lokalen Behörden sagen
trotz aller Gefahren lässt der Sturm
aber auch solche Bilder entstehen wie
hier am Lake Toulouse Minnesota
Schönheit ist eben manchmal trügerisch
jetzt zur Fußball Champions League der
Frauen da jubelten gestern Abend die
Wolfsburgerinnen ein Haus hoher Sieg im
letzten Gruppenspiel gegen St Pölten der
VfL gewann in Österreich mit acht zu
zwei und steht als Gruppensieger im
Finale nach Meisterschaft und Pokalsieg
2022 die Wolfsburgerin auch
international auf der volkskurs
zum Weihnachtsfest bereits in der
fünften Minute schlimmste Lena Latein
den Ball sehenswert zum 1:0 in den
Winkeln St Pölten nicht eben würdig und
die Wolfsburgerinnen Tor hungrig bis zum
Schluss der achte Treffer gelingt noch
in der 84 Minute Pauline Bremer legt
sich den Ball selbst vor und wird
gefeiert
war unser Ziel und das haben wir jetzt
erreicht von daher sind wir erstmal sehr
sehr zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis die
Auslosung fürs Viertelfinale in dem auch
die Fußballerinnen des FC Bayern stehen
gibt's dann am 10 Februar
der Kater der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft für die WM in Polen
und Schweden steht eine Mischung aus
routinierten und jungen Spielern
angeführt wird das Handball Team wieder
von Kapitän Johannes Golla mit 22 Jahren
ist Yuri Knorr der jüngste Spieler in
der Mannschaft von Trainer Alfred
Gislason erstes Spiel des dhb-teams am
13 januar gegen Katha
Linus Strasser ist gestern beim
legendären Nachtslalom in Madonna die
Campino Dritter geworden der Münchner
holte damit seinen ersten Saison
Podestplatz und schaffte die
WM-Qualifikation
Strasser schon im ersten Lauf mit einer
ganz starken Leistung konnte seine
Platzierung auch im Durchgang zwei
behaupten Sieger der Norweger Lukas
Platen vor Leukämie ja aus der Schweiz
zur Darts WM in London da ist Florian
Hempel als Erster von drei Deutschen
ausgeschieden in Runde zwei unterlag der
wahlköllner dem Weltranglisten 5 und mit
Favoriten Luke Humphries dabei lag
Hempel zunächst mit 2:1 in Führungen
stand kurz vor einer Sensation doch dann
zeigte der englische Darts Profi sein
ganzes Können und gewann schließlich
knapp mit drei zu zwei Sätzen
ab morgen Weihnachtsbaum sind London am
27 geht's dann weiter dritte Runde wir
sind dabei danke schön und sollte jemand
von ihnen Sorge haben ob es der
Weihnachtsmann rechtzeitig zum Fest
schafft da können wir etwas beruhigen
diese Bilder belegen er ist pünktlich in
Lappland losgefahren bei besten äußeren
Bedingungen
gleichzeitig gibt es allerdings aktuelle
Aufnahmen aus Florida angeblich auch der
Weihnachtsmann unter Wasser nur ohne
Rentiere
und winkend auch schön sicher ist nur
eins hier wird dieses Weihnachten nicht
weiß auch heute abend warnt der Deutsche
Wetterdienst vor Dauerregen im
Schwarzwald und im Allgäu mehr dazu
gleich von Katja horneffer
Marietta Slomka begrüßt sie ihm heute
journal um Viertel vor elf machen Sie
sich einen schönen Abend noch und bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend im Schwarzwald hat es in den
vergangenen 36 Stunden zum Teil schon
mehr als 80 Liter Regensburg
Quadratmeter gegeben das hängt zusammen
mit diesem Tief hier über Deutschland
und es kommen weitere tiefen hinterher
es bleibt bei uns mild heute lagen die
Temperaturen zum Beispiel am Ärmelkanal
mit 14 Grad nur wenig unter denen am
Mittelmeer das ist so mild ist macht sie
auch in der Nacht bemerkbar die
Temperaturen sinken meist auf 11 bis 7
Grad und nur nordöstlich der Elbe wird
bei 4 bis 1 Grad etwas kälter der Regen
sieht allmählich weiter nach Nordosten
am Alpenrand aber vor allen Dingen hier
im Allgäu kann es noch kräftig weiter
regnen auch morgen am Vormittag regnet
es dann noch dann lässt dort der Regen
nach und die Regenwolken hier im
Nordosten verziehen sich auch langsam
ostwärts meistens hin und wieder sehen
sie auch mal die Sonne und es kann auch
weitere Regenschauer geben besonders
kräftig wird der Wind an der Nordsee und
die Temperaturen sind ähnlich mild wie
heute unser warten meistwerte von 7 14
Grad und nur in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
und in Schleswig-Holstein bleibt es bei
drei bis fünf Grad etwas kälter der
erste Weihnachtsfeiertag bringt dann
mehr Sonnenschein es gibt Regen vor
allen Dingen Richtung
Nordrhein-Westfalen und Niedersachsen
der zweite Weihnachtsfeiertag allerdings
der bringt uns dann mehr Regen und auch
sogar mal ein gewitterak guten Abend